believe it or not this is joe biden's
third attempt
to run for president history is lost
when you live in the eternal present as
we are now
but it's worth remembering some facts
three times
the first time biden ran was in 1988
that was before most of the people who
work on the show were born
and he was caught lying about his
biography in speeches and forced to drop
out
biden suggested to audiences that he had
grown up in a coal mining family
in wales that's not true joe biden is
actually from america
his father sold cars in wilmington biden
went to catholic prep school in the
suburbs
so it was pretty embarrassing it took 20
years before biden ran again and when he
did
it did not go well in 2008 joe biden got
a total
of one percent of the vote in the iowa
caucuses and he dropped out
that night joe biden whatever his
strengths
turns out to be so bad at running for
president that even barack obama
supposedly his close friend
repeatedly refused to endorse him he
just can't win
that was barack obama's view then the
wuhan coronavirus arrived
democratic governors shut down the
country millions lost their jobs
the economy tanked americans huddled in
their homes cut off from one another
and deeply miserable from his basement
strategically cloistered away in silence
joe biden shot ahead in the polls not
because of anything he did
he just happened to be there as of
tonight joe biden could win the race
unfortunately if he does joe biden
cannot govern the country he isn't
capable of it he's all but admitted that
he said he won't run for a second term
so biden's running mate will be the most
consequential vp pick in american
history and soon we'll know who it is
apparently the announcement is coming in
the next week as of tonight senator
kamala harris of california seems like
the front runner she's certainly the
best known
harris is a product of the same highly
credentialed yet deeply unimpressive
world that spawned
much of our media needless to say they
love her she's one of them
the public though has been much less
impressed including democrats
harris was so unpopular with democratic
primary voters that she never made it to
the first
vote in the primaries when she dropped
out in december harris was polling
around three percent
the wrap on harris in exit polls is that
she's a fraud she doesn't really believe
in anything she'll say whatever it takes
of course that is
also harris's primary strength here she
is promising free health care to illegal
aliens
so you support giving universal health
care medicare for all to people who are
in this country illegally
let me just be very clear about this i
am opposed to
any policy that would deny in our
country
any human being from access to public
safety
public education or public health period
oh now wait a second you may be
wondering
i'm sitting in my house maybe unemployed
paying a huge percentage of my net worth
for health care
so why should people who aren't even
allowed to be in this country in the
first place
get it for free at my expense and by the
way how can a government that's already
27 trillion dollars in debt afford to
pay for the rest of the world's medical
bills
now those are all good questions kamala
harris has no answers fixing problems is
not the point of the exercise
winning is the point and over the years
harris has been willing to do pretty
much whatever it takes to win
including use the power of her office to
crush political opponents
as the attorney general of california
harris relentlessly defended her big
donors in the abortion industry
when a journalist called david deliden
criticized planned parenthood in a
documentary
kimmel herrera sent the police to his
home delident later described the
authoritarian nightmare harris unleashed
on his
life they got a highly political search
warrant
to conduct a political raid on my home
to seize the unreleased undercover
footage by the way it's black letter
california law
that you're not supposed to get a search
warrant to seize the unpublished
materials of a journalist whether
citizen journalist professional
journalist
but that's what kamala harris went ahead
and did at the behest of planned
parenthood
in order to cover up for them in order
to protect them from increased further
scrutiny
for the crimes of selling aborted baby
body parts sometimes from
criminal partial birth abortions so i
think we can conclude from this
episode that kamala harris or any
politician
willing to use law enforcement to stop
journalism she doesn't like
probably doesn't care too much about
civil liberties or equality under the
law
and indeed she doesn't harris supports
allowing universities and employers to
discriminate based on the skin color of
applicants what decade is this she
supports race-based reparations
she'd like to rewrite the constitution
to eliminate the electoral college
because it's inconvenient
to give you some perspective on these
positions just 10 years ago
barack obama would have run away from
them that's how much the democratic
party has changed
and if you're looking at more evidence
of that change you should also know that
joe biden is considering congresswoman
karen bass of los angeles as his running
mate
she's also on the short list unlike
kamala harris
karen bass is not a fraud karen bass
means it
she's sincere she's an unapologetic
left-wing bomb thrower who spent
decades working to help fidel castro in
his
cold war against the united states karen
bass kept praising fidel castro
all the way to his death just four years
ago
in the 1970s karen bass belonged to a
group that the la police department
accused
of training revolutionaries in quote
terrorist tactics and guerrilla warfare
bass apparently visited cuba multiple
times a year
so it's not pejorative to note that
karen bass is not a mainstream figure
she literally co-sponsored the new way
forward act
that is a lunatic bill that would force
the u.s government to reimport a
taxpayer expense
hundreds of thousands of illegal aliens
whom we've deported for committing
crimes
bring them back here in many case
violent crimes for real
karen bass is so extreme that like
kamala harris by the way
she's currently trying to repeal
california's main
anti-discrimination law bass wants to
make racial discrimination
legal as it was before the civil rights
movement we're not overstating this
karen bass has issued press releases
bragging about it
you may not have heard about any of this
the details are so shocking
that virtually no media outlet bothers
to cover them but it is all
real look it up before it's scrubbed
keep in mind this
is the person these are the people who
could soon be running our country